[موسيقى]
هكذا عرفت سيريلانكا عن جزء من هويتها
التي جاءت الى حديقه السويدي ضمن فعاليات
موسم الرياض ادت فيها فرقه سريلانكيه رقصه
استعراضيه لتعريف الجمهور بجزء من التراث
الشعبي في مجال الزراعه
لبلده قريبه من البحر والاداء الذي قدموه
هنا اليوم هو عباره عن اغنيه زراعيه تعبر
عن تقاليد الزراعه وتحفيز المزارعين خلال
عملهم
[موسيقى]
ومن سيرلانكا الى اندونيسيا التي استغلت
الموسيقى والرقص والادوات الموسيقيه
الخاصه بهم في استقطاب جمهور الموسم
وتعريفهم على جانب اندونيسيا الابداعي
وطبيعتها
[موسيقى]
كثيره يعني في رقصه الطاووس
طائر النصر
اند سيست اه في همم يعني ياريس بلوز هنالك
ملابس من اندونيسيا من مناطق مختلفه ونعرض
كذلك ملابس اندونيسيا التراثيه
زوار الحديقه استمتعوا من خلال هذه
الفعاليه بالتعرف على استخدام ادوات
الموسيقى كما استمتعنا نحن بتجربه الملابس
التراثيه
من الرياض شهد المتروك العربيه